Sarah I have to ask obviously you know
you are just synonymous with like this
sort of Supernatural TV genre I mean
you're swapping vampires for werewolves
though Buffy did encounter werewolves
what about it the show or the genre did
you want to return to
someone said something earlier today
that really stuck with me which is
superhuman allows you to tell the most
human stories and it really does it sets
a stage where you're accepting of these
stories but not hit over the head and
the beauty of Buffy was we used the
monsters as a metaphor for the horrors
of adolescence and what Jeff is really
doing with this show is the monsters are
the metaphor for the isolation the
anxiety that we're all feeling now the
loss of our people you know we went
through two and a half years of not
being able to be faced if we're still
not sitting in the same room together
and what that's done to us and how we
communicate and the fact that as we
become more and more digitally connected
we're just becoming more and more
emotionally disconnected and I think
it's a really important story to tell
and to normalize
and that's what Supernatural really
allows you to do it allows you to tell
those tough stories in a way that's a
fun water cooler but you leave really
thinking about something important
I know that it's a great way to put it
um Rodrigo um I feel like in the trailer
I saw a little bit of a moment between
your character and Sarah's character
what can you tease about what's the
connection that your two characters have
I don't know
um you might have to watch and find out
yeah but did you did you feel like
something going on like a little
atmosphere attention attention there is
tension lots of tension uh just because
Rodrigo can smolder like nope
you do though you do smaller like it's
it's great and I love it I'm a fan I'm
here for it okay uh yeah I mean they
have a a very interesting Dynamic that
evolves throughout the show
um you have to be you know by episode
four or five you're gonna get a lot and
then
when you get to eight
you'll be like I didn't see that coming
yep
that's pretty much all I can say
okay that was good that was good
um Sarah I loved recently you talked
about how you want to be a safety net
for the younger actors on this show
because that sort of I met I met Rodrigo
oh
sorry
no you're good um is that kind of a part
of the reason you wanted to be executive
producer on this I think it's important
I think that on any set the mood the
tone it comes from up above and I was
able to create an atmosphere on this
show that I've always wanted that I
wished I'd had when I was that age and
that's a atmosphere that's communicative
and collaborative where people no matter
what your job is if you're a guest cast
a main cast a PA that you had someone
that would listen to you someone that
would hear you and to make it a great
experience at the end of the day we have
the greatest job we're making movies and
TV like that's pretty much as cool as it
gets and it should be an environment
that is safe and I just I wanted to have
you know I wanted to give the young cast
Rodrigo you know the experience that I
wished I'd had
you did very successfully
that's wonderful
um lastly you know I know Jeff was the
you know behind Teen Wolf and now he's
also the developer of this show as well
could we potentially see a crossover
between the the you know Teen Wolf
characters and Wolfpack characters
I don't think so I think the Canon is
very different I think that you might
see actors in fact we have one actor I
can think of later on in the show who
was on to a couple actually that did
some episodes you might see people but I
don't think
you know they're they're very different
lore and I think it's confusing if
because rules that might work for one
might not you know it's like Buffy and
Twilight right like but vampires can't
go out in the light vampires can go out
in the light you know they're very you
gotta you gotta stick in your lane
yep
all right well thank you guys so much I
hope you have a good rest of your day
thank you you too